(bright organ music)
- I'm a pastor.
(bright organ music continues)
- So what about an introduction
to start things off?
My name is Jay, I'm an Episcopal priest.
- I'm Don, a pastor, non-denominational.
- Dominic, Lutheran pastor.
- Paul, a youth pastor, SPC.
- Paul wore a whole suit,
and I was like, oh, maybe
he's overcompensating.
Like, "I don't know what a
pastor would wear on a Saturday,
maybe it's this suit."
- So I'm Zach, former
Calvary Chapel pastor,
and now like fully...
- Oh, wait.
- Fully?
- [Zach] Calvary guy.
- Whoa, yes.
- Come on bro.
(background laughter)
- Yeah, hence the tattoos and stuff.
I think my strategy is gonna be this idea
of like really trying to
just hear the heart behind,
like why people are pastoring.
- Daniel, also youth
pastor, non-denominational.
- I'm Anna, I'm actually
non-denominational,
kind of all over the place over the years.
- I mean I have question like, education?
So Seminary, maybe degrees, I don't know.
- Seminary, Theological Studies.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Where at?
- Kings College as well
as Oxford University.
- Oh, okay, yeah.
- Was that like an MA or was it a MBA?
- You're drilling me in, aren't you?
- I know.
(group laughing)
- I'm absolutely drilling you in.
- He's coming for you, dude.
- Henry, your turn, your turn.
- Oh, my turn?
- Your turn, yeah, man.
- So give it to him.
- So I'm in a MA program at
Western Seminary currently.
- I went to Calvary Temple Bible college.
- Come on dude.
- And then did the Veritas program.
So degree in Theology with
a focus in Biblical Studies.
- Oh sweet
- Yeah.
- Actually not really
a formal institution,
but I grew up in such a rural area,
there was just nothing for so far.
So more of, almost more
of like an apprenticeship kind of context.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Tiny town with tinier towns around it.
So we all would kind of come to the same
Lutheran church primarily
when I was studying.
- What kind of Lutheran church?
- Again, such a small
area, that just Lutheran.
(laughing)
There's so few people to get-
- Generic brand.
- Yes, generic.
- [Don] Generic.
- Run of the mill Lutheran.
- Gotcha.
- I like that.
- Immediately I thought,
"Well, if she's a Lutheran pastor
she would definitely say which
denomination she would be."
- Sorry.
- What town did you grow up in?
- [Anna] Upper Michigan actually.
Very small area.
- What town?
- Near Marquette, is kind of one
of the big cities around there, but
- Gotcha.
- It's, it's the one
that someone would know.
- Anna spoke in very general terms.
I don't even think she knew the city
that she came from, but she knew the city
that was next to the city she came from?
And at that point I was done.
- You mentioned that you didn't grow up
in the church?
- [Daniel] Right.
- More of that going around?
- [Zach] Sure.
- Okay, totally.
- So I've been there all
my life, was baptized
at seven years old.
I don't think I really became a believer
until I was 30 to be perfectly honest.
- Okay.
- I did it
because I was brought up
and this is what you're supposed to do.
You do what they do and what they say
and you believe blah, blah, blah, blah.
So, yeah.
And then I got kicked out.
(record scratching)
(everyone laughs)
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
(computer clicks)
- From what I knew about Lutheran's,
there should have been
a very specific answer
to that question and that
kind of threw me off.
(computer clicks)
- A-N-N-A. Done
(Don laughs)
(buzzer buzzes)
- Of course the woman's not a pastor.
- So that's-
- Check your bias.
- Listen I . . . .
- Bye.
(Anna laughs)
- Sorry, dude.
- Being the only woman in the group today
was a little tricky.
Obviously not being able
to always edge my way
into the conversation, was not able
to present it in the way
that I would've liked
and that I thought would've
been more effective.
- I walked in and I was so happy
that there was a female pastor
because they're the only types of people
that are as rare as gay
pastors like myself.
It's very much still new
where we're seeing queer pastors
and queer worship leaders
and queer Christians.
- Tell me. You got kicked out for what?
- I got kicked out.
Well, I got kicked out
because I was in the church.
And as I grew older in the church,
I began to ask questions.
That to me were very obvious.
- Yeah.
- What was one of those questions?
- Is baptism essential for salvation?
- Yeah.
- You know, communion some of
those battleground questions
that oftentimes separate
faiths and denominations yeah.
- I pastored high school kids for years
and I never had any of them
asking me that question.
- I want to know what everybody's
ministry responsibilities
are and what you're
currently teaching through.
- Yeah, so I'm an
assistant teaching pastor,
so we're replanting, revitalizing.
So I'm an elder and a teaching pastor.
- I serve at a small Korean
church in La Mirada, California
and I take care of the youth ministry.
- So I'm kind of semi-retired.
I also don't have a congregation,
although I work with one.
It's an little Episcopal
church in San Clemente.
I also have a weird job
that I'm chaplain to
a governmental agency.
- Jay answered the question
about being retired,
but he never indicated
what he was retired from.
And after years of being
in ministry or serving,
I thought there would've
been a culmination
of his life experiences.
And now he's doing a
part-time assistant thing?
And I thought,
"Okay, so we've slipped
into some unknown factors
about yourself, Jay."
- I don't pastor a church.
I pastor pastors.
- Oh, lovely.
- So I work for a denomination
and I preach at different
congregations every week.
- Wow.
- I'm not in the pulpit right now,
but I am teaching in small
groups, conversations.
There's a lot of dogmatic positions
that are just generalized
for Christiandom.
- So I have a question.
I mean, when was the
last time like you were
in a hospital room with somebody
and what comfort did you give them
in a time that was critical?
- Oh, I hate this question.
- I think that someone who
is in pastoral ministry
it's more than just
preaching and teaching.
Well, I felt a question
that would get at that
about how somebody gives the comfort
and the peace of the presence
of God would really indicate
whether or not they were a pastor
and they were involved
in that type of ministry.
Last time I was in the
hospital was not too long ago.
It was, I'd actually become almost a
medical proxy for a
family friend's mother.
She was elderly and just
kind of going through it.
And it was very, very tender for me.
But the comfort that I gave was knowing
that her family was nearby.
And knowing that beyond this moment
when she stepped out of time into eternity
she would be in the
place she longed to be.
- I've only had to do it once.
And it was very recent
and I hated it with
every fiber of my being,
because it was for
somebody that like I loved.
And it was a lot of waiting and quiet
and like very, very soft prayers
and just kind of being there.
And I'm shaking. I hated it.
(bell ringing)
(air whooshing)
(upbeat music)
(computer clicks)
- The thing that I thought I spotted was
that he was just trying too hard.
(computer clicks)
- The way that he was
answering the questions
was very old school.
(computer clicks)
(buzzer buzzes)
- Ah, do y'all know Jesus?
- Sorry brother.
(All contestants laugh)
- Sorry dude.
- I see what's happening.
First the woman, then the
black man, the gay is next.
(chuckles)
I see what's happening.
- What the devil? Me?
I question everybody else left up there.
Do they know Jesus? 'Cause I know Him.
(air rumbling)
- [Announcer] If you think
the Mole is still in the box
and you wanna continue playing the game,
please raise your hand.
- So let's start with the question of
what does atheism mean to you?
- I talk to my kids a
lot about agnosticism.
- Yeah.
- More than I talk about atheism.
- Yeah. Right.
- Just, you know, because of the
oversimplification of like, as an atheist,
"I don't believe in God." Well it's like,
"Well what is God?"
- I go back to like what
Augustine of Hippo said.
Like "All hearts are restless
until they find rest in God."
An atheist is not the enemy. It's not.
Just because you don't believe in the God
that I love and serve.
- Correct.
- Doesn't mean you're the enemy.
It means that you're
restless in your heart
and you're trying to search
for meaning and belonging
in anything other than God.
- I'd be curious to know anybody on stage
that did not have a real
serious questioning time?
- You, you start.
- [Zach] Yeah go for it.
- You are very quiet.
(everyone laughs)
And that just a little sus to me.
- [Zach] What was the question?
You are the best dressed so.
(laughing)
- I'm a little overdressed today.
- So the question was, have
I ever wrestled with faith?
To be honest,
I wrestle more with my
calling more than my faith.
My faith, once I had an
experience and encounter with God
out of drug addiction, that,
my faith was pretty much, pretty solid.
But with the calling,
I think I wrestled
countless amount of times,
In high school, my
parents decided to split
and that's when I really went on a frenzy
with drug addiction.
I struggled with meth, crystal
meth from my junior year.
I think that's what really
put me to the pit of my life,
the most rock bottom of my life.
And the only way I could go is to look up.
- So I have a question.
How do we feel about eschatology?
- Well we're a Millennial.
- You're all millennial? Okay.
- Very cool.
- So, okay.
Yeah, we are in the end times.
We were the second Jesus
said it was finished.
- Yeah I have a lot more openness
to the (indistinct) position than I did.
Growing up Calvary County chapel
was like hyperdipensational.
- Yeah! And this is a really,
I'm like "This is such a,
- Hyperdipensational.
- sensitive subject"
- Like hyper dispensational
(indistinct), you know
- Because of the sensationalism.
- Because of your background?
- Yeah and so.
- So I know that, yeah, that's cool.
- Okay, you know, I don't
expect the end time anytime, so.
- Okay.
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
(computer clicks)
- I sensed maybe a
little bit of woundedness
that he was putting forth and wondering
if maybe that was part of what
he was using as a mask there.
(computer clicks)
- I won't lie to you.
Jay looked super familiar
and I was banking on him
being a paid actor that I
had seen in something before.
(computer clicks)
- [Announcer] There was a tie.
The tie is between Jay and Daniel.
- (beep)
- [Announcer] I will give
you each on the clock
30 seconds to state your case.
- You know, I don't know what to say,
except that I think we should have,
I should have not voted
for the, for the redo.
Other than that, you know,
went to seminary 85 to 88,
Mdiv, Episcopal priest
for around 35 years.
I thought what was gonna do
me in is I'm really liberal
and you guys just killed me on that.
So, so that's, that's basically it.
(bell rings)
- I know what to say, I am a pastor,
please don't vote me out.
(group laughter)
It's as simple as that,
I know that I've been
ordained for a bit and
I'm in this like new congregation
I'm really excited about.
And the reason that I actually came was
because I heard that there
was some cash and I was like
"I really want to take the
kids on like a cool trip."
And so I really want to like split some
of this cash for the
kids in the youth group.
So that's why I'm here.
And I don't wanna get voted out.
Also don't be homophobic in June.
(background laughter)
(bell rings)
- I was a youth pastor, man.
(computer clicks)
Like we had budgets
for that kind of stuff.
Like I didn't use to use
my own personal money.
- I definitely saw the heart in Jay
and I felt like Daniel was
more of a presentation.
(computer clicks)
(buzzer rings)
(beep)
- I told you.
- Wow, wow.
- Called it.
- Wow.
- If the lights turn green
that means the mole is out and you win.
If the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
3, 2, 1.
(calm music)
- Nice, good job guys.
(applause)
Can the moles please
reveal themselves 1, 2, 3.
- Wow.
- But I'm gonna pray
against the rest of you.
(group laughter)
- Oh yeah.
- My, my apologies man.
- Absolutely.
- My apologies.
- And Calvary Chapel,
all of that was real?
- I do have a degree in Theology
from Calvary Chapel Bible.
- Got it.
- A big part of it was a personal desire
for knowledge and understanding
of my own existence.
So that was really what drove the course.
And I wanted to feel like
I was doing everything
I could to get those answers.
- So I have actually worked in the church
for about eight years, total
as a pianist and organist
on and off.
- Oh.
- So I had a lot to draw from.
- Here's what got me, as a Lutheran,
I know there are no general Lutherans.
- Yes, yes, that got me.
- Well, no, that really
is the thing though,
from such a loosely populated area that
that really is the case is
there's so little that even
brings people together.
There's a lot of churches that are people
who are strongly Catholic,
strongly Lutheran.
That will all be in the same place
because like a whole town
will be like a gas station
a corner store and 10 houses.
- So we are very much in a turning point
in the community when it comes
to queer individuals in Christianity,
even though I do not
subscribe to Christianity,
it's great to see at least a portion
of this community that
has such a large history
of having a negative agenda
towards us as a community,
opening up their eyes,
admitting their wrongs,
apologizing and seeking reconciliation.
And I think that it can only, you know
get better so long as they
continue to move on that track.
- Pastors actually think
a little bit more deeply
about people and the
condition of their soul.
And I really hope
that those who view this
would actually seek out
that type of spiritual direction as well
- Make the rain.
- Make it rain?
- Oh, make it rain.
- All right, okay.
- All right, we're going to do it.
- Yeah!
(background applause)